this show is brought to you by on it
go to honnett.com for all your
supplemental needs also
the church of what's happening now
is brought to you by lyft lyft knows
that their drivers are what keeps them
moving so they do everything they can to
make sure that drivers are happy on
every trip do me a favor
so join the ride sharing company that
believes in treating its people better
than any other
go to lyft.com
joey today right now and you get a 500
bonus
that slip.com slash joey listen you're
sitting there you don't know what to do
and mom bought you a new car but you
want to sit there and play video games
it's over go to lyft.com joey right now
and get a 500
new driver bonus that's limp.com
limited time only terms apply take that
mule lee
oh [ __ ]
little tom tom club
it's monday [ __ ] it's a beautiful
day to be alive
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
just when you thought it was safe
the church of what's happened now
[Music]
oh [ __ ] here we go here we go
little girl probably there for you on a
monday morning [ __ ] uncle joey
here
with his favorite [ __ ]
jewish person mr lee syed that's a big
honor i hope you guys had a fantastic
weekend
my weekend was tremendous uh i want to
applaud joe rogan
for letting me on his thousand podcast
i want to employ joe rogan for letting
me on the show at the comedy store
my set was [ __ ] up but i made it
through
if you came to the ice house last night
i love you [ __ ] too it's always
fun at the ice house that little room
if somebody farts everybody smells you
know what i'm saying so it's a it's a
great little [ __ ] party room yeah
we've been in that room since we since
we started from podcasts to one-man
shows
i've done a testicle testament to the
testicle testament stage two is like uh
it really is one of those places that it
relaxes you
as a comedian so you can let yourself go
and
you guys are sitting there going what
the [ __ ] you talking about joey just go
on a [ __ ] flop top no no no no no
there's something like the first time i
went to the comedy store i was so
uh
i wanted just to be in the original room
i didn't like the main room because i
bonded there
and the belly room just wasn't me why
did i want to go backwards
okay you like the original the belly
room when i first got to the store used
to be empty every night
14 18 34 people
they never really pushed it you had to
give the deposit on the room to get it
like 250 so that means you had to charge
the door it was a pain in the ass so i
just never
regressed and then one night mitzi came
up to me she was wearing another john
there
so i did this show called stories from
the cuban street
i think uh
our friend in austin bobby
sharon just got a copy from george the
original posters oh [ __ ] and i did
one-man shows up in the belly room at
the comedy store
but the beauty of it was
that one night that first one that i did
it was like
22 of my friends
and then i remember we snuck a bottle of
tequila upstairs okay
and uh myself ricky cruz this girl named
celine got rest his soul doug stanhope's
mother
doug stanley's mother was there that
night with us
like i can't forget who else is upstairs
but after the thing started dice came up
a bunch of people came up and that was
the birth of the original testicle
testament
but that night i was just upstairs
telling stories
and i was always in a rush on stage
that was my problem from the first time
i ever got on stage in 1991
i always was trying to get to the punch
line you're always trying to get to the
punch line you're always trying to get
to the punch line it took me
eight years nine years eight years to
really get the essence of comedy
and it was because of that show in the
belly room
because i told stories and that was the
first time for years
people begged me for years
i would talk to people late night we'd
be snorting blow or smoking dope
and they'd ask me a question and i tell
them a story and they go why don't you
say that on stage and i go because it
would never work
did you work on these stories no no at
that time no at that time you would ask
me a question i'd tell you a [ __ ]
answer
but even at that time people were going
to me joey you got to say that on stage
wow and i would go that i'm not saying i
was staying so one night i just put like
10 stories together
and i went up to the belly room
and i did three hours because there was
no show at 10 o'clock or nothing
so you they said you have it as long as
you want but i still remember we're
broke
like a bunch of us got together before
the thing there was no cocaine until
after the show
i did it in december of
so the first time you told stories you
told it for three hours talk three hours
what does that feel like
when you're up there for like long when
you're around doing those marathon sets
it was [ __ ] surreal like it was
i went to the store i didn't have a spot
in the original room okay we met over on
gardner across from elk behind el
compadre we didn't have enough money to
go to compadre then
like we had beer
and i got like a pint of tequila like
the little ones that you put in your
pocket like a [ __ ] jaguar on the
street
just like that
and me and my buddies drank the tequila
we smoked some dope like in those days
we had like three joints i think ralphie
may came later on
yeah it was just us it was like december
like
two weeks before christmas like the 16th
around that
people in town
so you didn't even so you didn't have
money for a bar but there's like we sold
like four tickets
it was at that time it was a struggling
time oh my god between the drug
addiction and i'd have gigs
but it wasn't what it is now
they were 200 gigs and 75 100 gigs and
seven hundred dollars and i did them
every night
see i did them every night and they
always said before i came to la that you
couldn't make money here
that's what people didn't hustle
i i can't i i'm not going to tell you i
made 200 grand doing 50 a night sets i
can't tell you that
but i made enough to drive a car pay for
a car pay rent snort coke you know i'm
saying keep myself from [ __ ] vittles
and i was 400 pounds
so you do make good money you make you
know in those days
on a monday night i would go to the
universal studios
and they had a room there and the guy
gave you 40 bucks
and then you went to the laugh actor you
made 25 and then you went to the comedy
store in may 15. but that's all in the
check
so you got 40 coming to you and you got
40 in your pocket that's monday night
tuesday night it picked up
fly and jeff garcia had casa latina
philippe esparza had a room in whittier
another kid that's that passed away god
bless his soul rudy medina he had a room
in uh at a country club he paid a
hundred felipe 15 a burrito
and jeff garcia and fly paid 40 bucks
and uh uh a free meal is it harder as a
quote unquote dirty comedian because
you're going all these places that i
know these were restaurants these were
bars they didn't give a [ __ ] no at these
places they want you to be obnoxious and
loud okay cool
those are the comics that do well in
those places oh witty comics have to
have a hard time in those rooms so they
avoid them
because they're just telling funny jokes
these are drunk people that have been
working hard all day the blue collar
people they should pull
they bet the [ __ ] lakers and now they
had to turn the lakers off for you for
you to go on stage [ __ ] you you better
be [ __ ] funny
and then wednesday somebody else had two
rooms
thursday you'd be off but i'd still have
a spot at the store
and then friday i would go like to
ventura and pick up 175
and then come home and do the comedy
store for 15 bucks
and then saturday i would pick up
another gig somewhere for 100 bucks
and rudy moreno had rooms for 40. the
brave bull paid 40 bucks
but he would give you three spots so you
make 120 bucks
and then you shop back to the comedy
store and picked up 15 and then check so
when like if it was like the first of
the month and you got some of these
spots would you put some of it towards
the rent for next month or it's all
towards coke until like the 20 well
here's the deal people
nothing happens until
you make it happen motion creates
motion once you stop moving
the the debris stopped some of the
famous once told me that
once you stop moving the breeze stops
so by you moving you generate action
you know i was telling these guys that i
used to work at a place that sold
uh screws and nails on the phone
guys i had to be there i had to be tip
top magoo
at 4 00 am because 4 am was 7 am on the
east coast and the people who need
schools the contractors are coming into
their office oh
so they wanted you to call them
and in those days i used to get every
lead when i tell you every delete
when i tell you something i tell you
something every day right that i went in
there monday through friday
i faxed 10 different bookers
whether they knew me or didn't know me
and at that time nobody knew who the
[ __ ] i was
i had done
maybe the pilot and i had done maybe
basketball
so that's my stand-up was mediocre but i
knew to get better i had to go on the
road because that's like that must be a
weird part because of stand up because
you can't really fax you can fax and
tell them what credits you have no no
nothing about you my name is joey diaz
i've been in baseball i shot a pilot for
cbs
named bronx county and i've been a
regular at the comedy store for the last
four years
i'm looking for feature work and i would
put the calendar of april
may and june let's say i was pitching
those three months right and i would put
imaginary dates on there but not really
i was never into bullshitting on resumes
it's too easy to at first i would put
like let's say i was doing lee's pork
chop house right in pomona california i
would put lee's comedy joint but like
that right in your league you're
following me yeah you're following me so
i was doing that type of [ __ ] and you
know what guys it took
i did that every day for [ __ ] months
would you describe yourself like i'm a
no i'm a
nothing at all
the better and they'd call you
listen to me bro nobody ever [ __ ]
called me for about four [ __ ] months
what are you kidding you want me to tell
you and then no they didn't call me
i would put on there how you doing my
name is joey diaz i'm a comedian from
los angeles i'm a comedian from new
jersey
living in california
i would i started in denver colorado at
the comedy works in boulder i won the
bex boulder broke a competition and came
in sixth in the seattle comedy
competition
i don't know if you watched television
but i was in the movie baseball with
whatever the zucker brothers and the
guys from south park and i was also
in a bronx pilot named bronx canada cbs
pilot named bronx county
i'm looking for feature work in your
area i have family in your area you
always have family in the area because
that means people are going to come to
the shows
oh i think we're going to try to get
them out of buying a hotel room no you
always have you just want to get the gig
they'll ask you on the phone do you have
family yeah but it's
in kentucky it's an hour away oh okay
now you got them but they're going to
give you the date already
you make it very vague but not really
i never sent the tape in those days
that's what i would say
that's what i would send and nobody ever
called me back
nobody ever called me back
and i was dating this girl who lived in
michigan
and one of the biggest talent agencies
in the midwest they're still there great
company
is uh
[ __ ]
i forget what the guy's name but the guy
who booked me there was marcolo these
people i'm talking about they own the
club in grand rapids
they've been around for a long time the
[ __ ] father was phenomenal great guy
the father
the father was solid the father when i
got into comedy
he's still alive he just gave the
business to his sons
but the father had
60 rooms and uh 16 nights jesus and it
booked detroit he booked this that day
he owned all those clubs
i'm not he just booked them kaya it was
like midwest town agency but the booker
at the time his name was marcolo
i can't think of his [ __ ] owner's
name
and next thing you know
i just i was going to michigan guys just
like
and i go you know what i'm going to do
i'm just going to call my caller
and take a chance columbus did
and i picked up the phone after four
months of faxing them and not hearing
the [ __ ] peep i picked up the phone i
go mark how you doing joey diaz he goes
how are you i go mark i need a favor he
goes what's going on i know i'm coming
up to michigan my girlfriend lives in
niles
and i just don't want to sit there with
her family for five days
i'm looking for feature work man
i know you got feature work is there
anything he goes you know what i do have
a week
and he gave me four nights
but one of them ended in grand rapids
where i go now
for uh
that
mr doctor grins right and and you worked
for him before you said you never never
said that you know sending them the
faxes and sending the faxes never sent
them a [ __ ] tape nothing he booked me
he gave me the benefit of the doubt do
you remember the faxes or no yeah yeah
yeah he knew the name and he i finally
called him and he knew the name
obviously and he [ __ ] picked up the
phone
and i told him like a man what my
situation was i'm not looking at a
headline
see if i would have called him look at
the headline now you got a problem right
now you got to show them tapes and
i'm just looking at a feature
i'm not looking for much he didn't even
pay me much they paid me like 75 bucks a
night
but i didn't give a [ __ ]
i just wanted to get in to work yeah i
wanted to get him with him so the first
night it was like grand then michigan
something like that where they had like
sailboats outside what time of year was
it it's [ __ ] december it's playing
with [ __ ] it's freezing
maybe there's 30 people
the second night was at like a bar
restaurant type pair plays then i had a
night off then friday and saturday used
to have two clubs in grand rapids dr
grins
that's huge now and they had a smaller
club that they booked
okay are they close to each other i
don't know how big grand rapids is
half of it you know was on the other
side of town okay gotcha and one of them
as a feature act
on a friday night
and
i'm on stage just doing what i do at the
company store
at that time i was starting to click
it was
98.99 and i was
starting to get it
were you telling stories on stage yet no
no no
no no no no no
i was very blue
but very machine gunny
no substance just machine gunning
and i had this room [ __ ] howard and
that night
that owner of that company right walked
into that club
and the headliner went up to him
and he was like hey man
he starts telling this guy all about his
career
and this guy that owns the company looks
at me goes
i wouldn't worry about what you're doing
i'd worry about do you see what this guy
that you're gonna follow is doing
and i remember my i was the feature and
i got off and he came up to me and he
introduced himself and
he was a [ __ ] gentleman he goes dog
you're stronger than a feature
next time i got a headline i was like
perfect
like he got i got to see the guy like
people dying for this guy to see your
tape he just happened to walk and when i
was on stage i had no if i knew he was
on stage i would have ate a bag of dicks
and this was the guy who got you the
feature work this was fun
look at that i booked my work saturday
night and then this guy started
headlining me
he started headlining me in small rooms
and co-headlining me and featuring in
big
rooms [ __ ]
yeah i mean it seems like the money was
total
dog [ __ ]
like for a feature act from tuesday to
saturday i got 450
for one two three four five six seven
shows so what's 450 divided by seven
yeah it was nothing the feature and then
they put you up in a condo that
you wouldn't [ __ ] you know no no
buffalo was good buffalo was good
lansing was good they had a couple rooms
that were really [ __ ] good they
really did
64.
what's that
450 divided by seven yeah 64 hours of
[ __ ] set
but i would go everywhere
i would go everywhere all over michigan
i would he would send me to milwaukee i
did marquette universally like a student
lounge
you know that's what you have to do
sometimes
take short money and look i was on stage
and the guy came in it's funny
i don't watch that much tv
this weekend
i go into the [ __ ] i'm in my office
whatever
and i walk out and i see that my wife is
watching that movie with michael keaton
about ray kroc and it's called the
founder right
so i don't know how long she's been
watching it i'm interested in all those
type of movies you know right there when
i was watching that movie
i understood what i like about i don't
like sci-fi channeling none of that [ __ ]
i like semi-real stories but i want to
see the struggle absolutely and that
movie really shows you the struggle and
it shows you that
you know
nothing good happens
you know unless you get off the couch
number one but nothing good happens
unless you think outside the box now if
you watch that movie
and you watch the whole story
and this is a spoiler alert i don't give
a [ __ ]
if you watch the whole movie
yeah it is history you know if you watch
the whole movie
you really learn something about two
different
visions about two different views on
life
you could think about it as
um
that the guy kind of robbed him
or you could think about him as the two
guys were so stubborn
they let this guy rob
for the thousandth time i'm a 54 year
old man
lee you're 30 in reality estimated
you're 30.
look at lee turned pale on me when i
said he was third he's 20 29 he's
fearing 30. he's fearing 30. so
but right now let's say we got a kid in
here to come in here and he's 19. he's
out of college
no i'm sorry he's 21 he's out of college
and his uh
background his major is computer
engineering this guy could decipher
everything
and he falls in love with you he's
jewish he went to emerson
he contacts you
and he sits in with us one day and you
become friends with him and
next thing you know the kid's telling us
ideas
and you and me are like
[ __ ] this guy
you know saying like yeah he yeah we
want to do what you like
we're in but
every six months he would call us and
try to switch it up
but we're too stubborn
we're in this [ __ ] town that we don't
we don't see past
absolutely yeah it's so weird you could
walk
when you're in the game for too long
yeah it's so weird to watch it from the
outside
and get a clear point of view on it
we're never really objective with
ourselves until years later yeah we find
out why we did what we did and what was
[ __ ] going on you know
but this movie
my god i had to watch it like i watched
it from the middle to the end
and then today or yesterday i watched it
all over again from the beginning and it
was
it's not an academy award winner guys
but it's the kind of [ __ ] i like
it's kind of like not revenge but
revenge on yourself
that he was when he was facing adversity
he met somebody
and the guy this guy
listened to him
he had vision
he listened to him and what he was
chasing
was something completely different than
what should have been chased
for some reason this weekend i was
thinking about something
a lot
i was thinking about when i was
i was probably 19 years old
i had already robbed a jewelry store
i had already hidden in sarasota florida
for two
maybe two months and two weeks
i had gotten a job i had gotten back
and i got a job in a warehouse
in edgewater new jersey
where they build like frames for
enderman's deli and [ __ ] like that for
donuts like the displays at the stores
i got fired from that
and then i got a job
working at a hardware store
but i got arrested
while i worked because i used their van
and i had possession of stolen
uh stealing tools or whatever
when you have tools to do a robbery oh
yeah oh yeah possession of tools or
whatever
so the guy fired me so i really had my
back against the wall so i created my
own job i went into the city one day
where my mom used to know these dudes
who did numbers my mom had done numbers
with them for years and blah blah blah
and i want to i went over there and told
the guy the truth i said listen man i'm
looking for work
i can run errands i can pick up money
for here i'll do whatever the [ __ ] and
he goes you know what man this guy got
sick on me
i'm looking for a guy just to walk and
pick up little [ __ ] envelopes and
numbers that's it the neighbor is
protected they know you got numbers
they're not going to beat you up because
you got no cash
and after a while they know who you are
come over here every day at 10 o'clock
and every day i would [ __ ] uh go over
the
where i [ __ ] lived in i lived with
ferny
on 70th street in kennedy boulevard
right next to the gas station there
and i would [ __ ] take the bus to
george washington i would go the other
way which way would i go i would walk up
to bergen line avenue
i was a [ __ ] kid man
19 i dropped out of high school
i felt like [ __ ]
i just felt like [ __ ] you know
but the drugs and the alcohol and going
out my buddies
that really evened it out you know
and i would take the bus from bergen
line
to [ __ ] port authority
and then i would take the train
like i'd have to take two trains and i
have to take one i have to get to what
street
and then shoot over and then walk like
five blocks
and it was like 118th and like maybe
third or fourth avenue fifth avenue
and i'd get there by ten
and i'd open up the store with them and
i'd scrape the front
and i'd go get us breakfast like hammer
like sandwiches around the corner
sometimes they picked me up in my house
and we would go to
a diner and see caucus where they used
to have salt water taffy howard
johnson's right yeah
we would go to howard johnson's eat
breakfast talk about the strategy of the
day
and then we would shoot into [ __ ]
spanish harlem and do numbers from 10
o'clock to 3.
from 10 to 3 i walked i went to the
store and got coffee i went to the
supermarket and got rice i got ham they
would cook i was just a gopher
and in between that i had to go pick up
different [ __ ] envelopes with numbers
and at three o'clock the number would
come out for new york and that was it i
was done for the day they would ask me
if i needed cash i'd say yeah
they'd ask me how much i'd tell them a
hundred and then like that always they
gave me 140 a day
so i would work seven [ __ ] days a
week
give the rest of the check or something
yeah they're gonna give me the rest of
the czech league no they gave me the
rest in cash on fridays
oh so every day they would ask if you
wanted anything yeah
[ __ ]
that's like a perfect job for you so i
would take like 100 every other day
and it was like being guys i can't tell
you what it was like like i was [ __ ]
always broke and
i had a guarantee yard stick in my
pocket
i paid for rent for ferny
i would buy little groceries
but the rest i [ __ ] i had no other
bills
my bills in those days were maybe 300
bucks
and now i was making 140 a [ __ ] day
oh my god
are you crazy
and what did he do you save the rest
savings yeah oh please i was at the
savings account i even had a christmas
club again get the [ __ ] out of here
i would leave there i'd go buy a daily
news
i'd get like a soda
and i don't care how cold it was
i'd walk i'd find the spot that sold
weed
i'd buy a 20 bag of weed you know
i had a spot that gave me 20s of coke
and it was like a little over a quart or
an eighth so i'd get like four tenths of
a gram instead of two tenths of a gram
and the coke was fantastic
and then i jump on the train man
and i jump on the other train and then i
take the bus over the [ __ ] tunnel
and it dropped me off the bus home and
dropped me off on kennedy boulevard
right across the street
from what bar with the heck
and i caught like
50
feet from the door where i lived
sometimes i would go home
put some [ __ ] away
maybe take a shower comb my hair and i'd
go right across the street to that bar
or i'd wait i'd kill time
so i wouldn't spend so much money at the
bar
instead of going at eight you go at 10
and you spend less money
so for two hours i would watch tv and
make phone calls you know whatever the
[ __ ] i did in those days just killing
time it was a [ __ ] superb job
superb
i think i got fired like january 18th
i was there january 20th
and it snowed and i'd go there you know
i was there no matter what every day 10
o'clock then it would just pick me up
it got to the point they were just
picking me up i've grown up with these
guys like i knew these guys
i had grown up in their homes like i've
been at their homes when we were kids
what's the next step up is it someone
just answering a phone taking numbers
so there was a few days i would go
upstairs
and work the phones then after a while
like somebody couldn't come in till 12
on thursdays or something coco get on
the [ __ ] phones a piece of cake i
grew up around that
so i would call you you would tell me
what your number was or what your name
was
lately what's going on today nothing
you're ready yeah you got a pen yet
517 five dollar box 10
straight
so you'd write five and then the you
write five
in the ten dollar box you put a circle
around it
so you understand what i'm trying to say
but there are symbols for every bit
right so lee
and i would lee wants five dollars okay
on five seventeen so i would write five
seventeen he wants five dollars straight
and i would put five dollar box and i
put a circle around that five
that meant a five
what's the box mean box means if
175 comes out
gotcha you're following me so that's
what i would do that was my job and then
i would i would write on a pink slip rip
it give them a pink slip give the other
guy a pink slip and i would keep that
pencil gamble about anything and if that
number comes out right let's say he
better for five dollars
he gets
he gets 2500 in reality he gets 3 000
but i get 500 off the top
and then he gives me a tip which is
usually 500.
so that pink sleep like so sometimes i
would go upstairs and the phone would be
ringing they go coco get in there but i
had been doing it since i was in
catholic school with this dude
like when i was in catholic school in
the fifth grade and the fourth grade on
saturdays me
and i'm cousins with this guy julio
rodriguez
we're not really blood cousins but we
grew up together he's a big jiu jitsu
guy in new jersey gotcha okay he's my
dog he owns anaconda his brother rest in
peace
when we were in the fourth grade and you
can ask julie i can have julio call up
and tell you we were in the fourth grade
on saturdays i'd be home and instead of
[ __ ] around like most kids me and
guillot would go to the bronx
and we would do what i was doing
when i was
19. in the fourth grade and every week
they changed apartments
so every week we were in different
neighborhoods and then eventually you
went back to that apartment they would
just move around the apartments
jesus let me just move around every few
days every week every week every sunday
you have a new apartment
but you keep the other one so the cops
never [ __ ] know where you're at how
long do you build the apartments for a
whole year years for years you just keep
rotating and then after six months maybe
the least brace boom you get another
apartment that's how you did it back
then
but you got to remember new york city
gambling is a ticket it's a misdemeanor
it's a ticket i don't know what it is
today
but 30 years ago was a ticket so you
took the ticket you i mean eventually if
you got 10 tickets you're going to go to
[ __ ] prison
but
they would you could pay the cops off in
those days the cops are paid off on
numbers numbers don't hurt nobody
nobody loses their house with [ __ ]
numbers nobody sucks a dick over numbers
it's five dollars you can bet a dollar
you can call me in bet lee
uh 805 a dollar straight and a dollar
box
i think that pays you 500 bucks and pay
750 but i keep 250 off the top as a
bonus
and when do you collect this money
every week the guys for them to keep
calling they collect we they collect
every paid days like friday for some
people it's thursdays thursdays is a big
booking day to be honest with you to be
honest i don't think i don't remember
what day
was that collection day but nationally
usually
if you're working with a good book it's
thursday because they want to catch you
you lost monday night football
that the week up ends on monday
okay so the week goes monday through
monday
or tuesday through monday and they won't
let you bet again until you pay up so
the week starts thursday you got to pay
on thursday
you want to play thursday night football
you got to pay on thursday so i think
it's still the same i may be wrong i
don't know
the last couple of bets i put in i put
it in las vegas but the point of the
story was i had this job
and i loved it i loved it with all my
art i loved coming out of there at three
o'clock and just breathing new york city
air
that's the story i tell people that's
the reason why
one monday i went it was [ __ ]
freezing
it was [ __ ] freezing it was like i
was going over there for like five weeks
at this time
and it was [ __ ] freezing it was like
my sixth week there
it was like towards the end of february
and i get there and and when i get there
they go dog we're closing up today
when i get there is when i find out they
closed up
i didn't give a [ __ ] i was in the city
i'm in the city it's 10 in the morning
i'm fine
that's a beautiful day to be alive just
a little cold
i got money in my pocket to get me back
i had like 30 bucks
and i had a plan to buy weed anyway
so i went to the spot i usually go to
the buy weed
boom
and
they also had in those days they had
angel dust
and they would sell you angel dust for
three bucks
i don't want how much angel dust
if i took a joint and made the skinniest
joint you ever seen that's what it was
is that enough to get high oh that would
put you in zomboville
but you wouldn't put it in a joint you
wouldn't roll it and enjoy it by itself
you'd sprinkle it in a joint of the weed
they just sold you
so you put a tr a tray as they called it
into the one of the joints that you
bought
and that's the story i tell about the
time i smoked and after i smoked the
joint with the chick she told me she was
pregnant
yeah that's when that happens
that fateful day i was having a good old
time over there i really was i got into
gambling over there because around the
corner there was a gambling book
and it was just like las vegas you could
go in and go let me get 30 000 next
tonight give them the money and they
give you a bet and slip no way yeah it
was just like that
so i was getting into little gambling
over there i was winning
i was getting them for a hundred a week
and now when you actually studying or
were you just getting lucky you know i
was getting lucky with basketball in
those days there's parts of the year
where you're good with basketball the
lines are tricky i knew the knicks i
knew the
you know i had taken some beatings
already in basketball
timmy you know he knew his family knew a
lot about gambling do you remember the
catholic nix
well i did a lot of stupid [ __ ]
it doesn't matter i did a lot of stupid
[ __ ] but the painful thing about that
job was
that it was like july
i had been doing it for six months
normally i hadn't put away any money
but i had clothes
i was eating
i wasn't really getting in trouble you
know i knew i had some problems i think
at the time some people were looking for
me but it was nothing serious
at that time yes
people were looking for me and i was
going to new york every day i was
[ __ ] swimming in the [ __ ] shaky
ground
and i left
and i made a decision to leave because
one day when i was in there i was i was
like on the train back
and i thought to myself jesus [ __ ]
christ
what am i doing my life like i was a
[ __ ] loser
like we were talking about barton in
school yesterday this is
a year or two before bartending school
like i was just out of my wits
all i live for was to [ __ ] go out at
night
and hang out with my buddies and talk
[ __ ]
i was a lost soul and by this time my
friends were going to college
which made me feel inferior like you
just feel even shittier about yourself
and
i still remember that year going like
thanksgiving to the bar the night before
thanksgiving okay and everybody's home
with their little [ __ ] college
sweaters
and you're in the corner with your
[ __ ] hoodlum buddies and you feel
like shooting yourself
like really oh
my god
you know this movie called saint almost
five and there's a scene like that at
the bar where they come home for
thanksgiving
and they're all [ __ ] fancyed up and
you're the same [ __ ] mook in the
corner
that didn't go to college but your
father owns a construction company
so everybody comes back from school
and they're like oh my god we love
southern california
oh my god we love michigan and you know
they're like [ __ ] uh yeah i'm a
roofer
and they have no idea how much better
they have it in reality
well nobody knows dick at that age you
just know what you got and what you
don't got right and what you don't have
is that much farther away than what you
really think
at that age i could have had a job and
worked every day
i just [ __ ] you it's gonna take me
longer than a week [ __ ] you
you know what i'm saying i'm never going
to get that money
i'll never get that money even if i make
a budget
it'll be years before i get the money
that i'm looking to get
i used to get
tripped up with the cover letter part of
the job application like if i ever had
to write a cover letter i would just not
apply
i was way before the cover letter you
never had to write that uh
are you like writing letters yeah no i
wrote cover letters
when i got divorced in 91 i had to start
write writing like little cover letters
so i wrote like things that i had done i
never knew what to say accomplishments
everything that you did only magnified
so instead of saying
i was uh
a maintenance man
and a podcast studio
you say
you were a maintenance technician
at a major
pediatric media studio conglomerate yes
that leaves a big word so what did you
do there did you sweep did you clean the
toilets did you work on the computer
organized uh yes
materials those couple letters are just
[ __ ] issues yeah it's [ __ ] it's
not lying you can't lie on those things
because they'll bust you it's basically
your accomplishments
only with big words and
make it seem like you know you have a
maintenance technician third class
of the highest the highest order who
gives a friendship it'd be my dream to
be a maintenance technician that you're
you're picking up papers with a stick
with a nail at the end well you can't
you know i'm saying but that doesn't
matter as long as you sell it
right but the point of the raycon thing
the guy ray
was at the beginning he was listening to
an album like a hypnosis album and it
was 19 [ __ ] 40 guys 1950
and the guy was laying back and this is
way before anthony robbins this guy was
just saying that the key to all this
[ __ ]
is persistence
excuse me
and i remember sitting there after
hearing that the first time i told about
it last night like when i was driving
home from the ice house right to you and
i went home last night
i don't know what i did when i got home
last night i just sat around for like an
hour and cooled off and
i thought about that word and
how it's really [ __ ] real like the
first time he went to mcdonald brothers
they were like nah we don't want a
franchise
and then he went back with a different
offer and then he went back
and they're like this guy is a [ __ ]
persistent [ __ ] so we're the mcdonald's
brothers like
i don't want to say artists but they
they they were purists they like burgers
they had created something they had
worked hard
for what they had created they had
experimented
they had lost they had experimented then
they chopped it down to what was the
what they sold
and they made it into a a production
line
so you could have a burger in 30 seconds
and then they sold as an american
institution when you go into a a town
what do you see a church
it's got a cross on it
you see a city government building it's
got a flag on it and when you see
mcdonald's got the two arches on it
it was just a brilliant idea guys
it's amazing when you see american
ingenuity that's american ingenuity
but the main thing i got from that was
his persistence like
people have no idea what they need to do
like now i remember
we talk about selling
and i talked to you about selling all
the time i was a good salesman but i
wasn't a great salesman
you know why because when i was young i
didn't really want to focus on it
that was not what i wanted to do i
frowned upon that career which
if i would have stuck it out i would
have been a great salesman on the phone
i mean when i was 27 when i came out of
prison i got a great job offer to me
and if i would have got that job i could
have gotten any other [ __ ] job
because i would have just kept moving up
i just never gave it enough time
selling on the phone yeah like being an
indoor salesman for like a big
corporation
they don't know what you look like they
don't know you're a [ __ ] felon they
don't give a [ __ ] they just want you to
sell and sell appointments
you know what i'm saying so i'm just
selling sending you a package staying on
you
and then going listen i got a rep in
your area right now they come over there
and talk to you let me set it up for you
that type of [ __ ]
those guys those guys make
dough and then they make back end though
if you have the appointment you make
dough if you sell it
i make dough if they get something else
i make dough
so there's three or four levels of dough
there
see you and you end up making a lot of
money and they're sitting on a desk and
making oh yeah
you really can't you'd be surprised how
well telemarketers do
especially jobs that don't have a
ceiling on them
like if they do not have a ceiling like
i have the potential to go really make
as much money as you want i could
actually make eight grand today
that is a [ __ ] tremendous job to have
it's tremendous pressure on individual
but it really isn't
it really isn't when i was younger i did
that also
and i was good at it but i wasn't great
at it but
by what i've learned the last 10 years
in comedy and
how the funniest guys are not usually
the popular ones
and the one you know all that type of
[ __ ] taught me
[Music]
that
what we talking about
the sales the sales i could have been a
lot better at different parts of it well
do you think and it's like the oldest
question in the book
but
for people out there who are looking for
jobs can you
learn to be a good salesman because i
don't think i would be yes really i was
yeah to me it just seems like yes people
are like you're born to become no it's
all in the script
really it's all in the script
they designed the people who own that
company
spent thousands of dollars
on that marketing script oh the
telemarketer the telemarketer so that
company let's say i'm uh mattel
okay let's say i'm mattel
mattel is not just gonna sit there at
night and write a script and give it to
you
they're going to write a script to push
you a little bit throw you off your
chair
and set the appointment let me tell
once i start going off that script like
anything else in life
i start improvising and it all falls
apart
so they have an option for whatever the
person on the phone says
they have some response for you i have a
list of things
you know if you watch all those movies
boiler room they all have a list of
uh if you say something i say something
back
and i go keep going back i learned a
really good lesson
in like 1989
i went to the boulder toyota dealership
in bulk
great dealership like [ __ ] class a
dealership
you were not gonna go in there and set
the world on fire
but
a single guy
that's a great [ __ ] job
you know monday through saturday
sunday's off you have a day off during
the week if you want to if you're a
young guy you go you know what here's
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna go in every
day from nine to nine five days a week
i'm gonna take the day off the week
and blow off some steam and then take
sunday off and blow some steam
i did that kind of sort of but i made
dough but not the dough i should have
made because i was focused on other
things
like drugs and how to do drugs and be on
probation at the same time pee in a bowl
and not get caught
but that was a phenomenal job but the
point i'm trying to make is when i was
there i learned a valuable [ __ ]
lesson
and this was
when i got out of prison i read a book
telemarketing i i've spoken about in the
podcast but this was a lesson that was
brutal
so in those days you know the sales call
is
when you go like when you do the sale
when you call toyota when you call
toyota of van nuys okay and you go how
you doing can i speak to a salesman
okay so what an operator will do is show
okay no there's either two things that
happen
a slick salesman like me gives her a 20
in the beginning of the week
and says hey beautiful any sales calls
come in
ask for joey diaz i'm here all day today
give her 50 bucks forget about it she'll
give you a sales call from [ __ ] india
she'll give you the lease department
sales call it's amazing
but let's pretend you don't want to give
him a 50. you want to take a chance
columbus did and here your dealership an
operator goes sales call on line five
and 20 dudes run to the phone
and then they hello this is lee how can
i help you
hi i want to buy an 82 it says in the
paper okay
that's the way you do a sales call
and the guy improvises but at this
dealership i worked at it was owned by
the guy that owned the new orleans jazz
at the time
and he invested a lot of money in
training and what he did was he hired
this company from california
and what they did was they provided you
with
if you had like 10 salesmen they
provided you with two boxes
two boxes it was like two boxes in the
corner
and then those boxes were a phone
[Music]
and you had to sit there and on the
phone
on the wall in front of you
was all the things the guy was gonna say
and on to your right with all the things
you were gonna say
and before you could start working there
the guy would come in personally and
talk with you for three days the owner
the guy that ran this phone sales system
got it he would come in personally and
tell you listen to me and listen to me
correct
if you stick to the seven points i'm
talking about here
you will sell the car
but most importantly you'll get them in
here
so it's a percentage game
if you get 10 sales calls
if you call in okay
if you call in and go hi this is lisa
i'm looking for uh it says in the paper
you have a 2017
toyota corolla demo edition with uh
what color is that car
i can't even tell you the color
okay i don't know right now what i could
do is take your number
and call you back on a lot and call you
back i do know one thing okay hold on
one second hey larry
what's that call like what color
purple and it's beautiful just can't
they just
okay and the guy hears that lightly
i cover the phone but not really
he knows exactly what to say because we
do this every day
then he gets on the phone he goes all
right listen
it's ready to go it's beautiful and the
guy goes what type of mileage does it
have average miles
that's not a number yeah so it's 2017.
average miles what's the average mileage
an american puts out a car a year 15 000
miles
it's a 2017.
anyway listen the miles doesn't really
matter the car is beautiful and it's
ready to go
lee what's your last name and what time
can you get down here
sight and all too no you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're gonna go
no i want the exact mileage i want to
know the color i want to know if it has
the sports package
i can't tell you that lee listen it's
got everything do me a favor
grab my number let me give you the
address what time can you come down here
where you calling from i mean it just
hit you with points lee
and when you so you would be lazy now
number one they taped every conversation
uh were they listening right then yes no
no no they would they would come and you
would send the tapes daily okay so i'll
never forget this mary was her name
mary would go sales call line two
and you would have to pick up the phone
and go marry joe diaz and phone number
two
phone number two was the phone by the
window guess what i did let me tell you
how much of a sack of [ __ ] i was
i went over and disconnected the tape
recorder
so i could do whatever the [ __ ] i wanted
so they knew something was up they were
like suddenly disconnected both tape
recorders hilarious
i did that like two weeks in a row the
guy got pissed
at the meetings because he would come in
every wednesday from california and have
sales meetings and [ __ ]
at nine o'clock and talk about the
progress on the phone the guy was
phenomenal
thinking about it now in hindsight
and he would say lisayet last week you
took 11 sales calls and you sold no cars
why do you think that was and you go i
don't know the guy in the office he'd
play your [ __ ] sales pitches
and he look you to go where in the sales
pitch does it say
fifteen thousand four hundred like he
would just he wouldn't grill you
but he'd go you lost the sale right
there
and dog so he i they started figuring
out they put a lock on who was he was he
like the master car salesman he was a
phone guy that was big time phone
communication guy and this company
started up and they consulted a bunch of
[ __ ] like i
listened to the story i so i didn't like
the guy okay
he just seemed too [ __ ] whitey tidy
for me i just got out of prison
he was always on time
and then he started listening to me and
one day he got so pissed immediately he
goes by the way mr diaz you're off the
phone for two weeks
and i was like what are you talking
about man he goes your percentage is a
zero
i was pissed away he hurt my feelings he
said it to me in front of anybody there
was only two people ever
in the history that he was there he had
to take off the phones because they were
so bad
were you not following the script not i
would follow two or three steps and then
give up
and cave
he didn't care if you did that because a
human does that by natural he would tell
you why you would do that
but he wanted you to go against yourself
and stick to the pitch and go back to
those six to it was really
so what happened was
when everybody left the room
i kind of got in his face not in the
violent way i just approached him and
asked him what's going on he goes
what we're going to do is you and i are
going to come back
next wednesday we're going to meet
i'm taking you off the floor and we're
gonna go through the whole thing and i
was kind of pissed
i really i was young i was stubborn
i was like this is [ __ ] i'm gonna
lose money i wasn't gonna lose no money
this guy sat me down and went through
the whole thing
which is him and i
for three [ __ ] hours laying a room
with suits on
and he broke it down to me like a
[ __ ] science
and he started taking charts out and
[ __ ] books and graphs something money
balls car sales this guy was brilliant
no he knew about phones
he knew that you're not supposed to sell
the car on the phone
you're selling the appointment
i don't want you to ever sell a car on
the phone
don't it doesn't matter what color it is
it really doesn't we could get you any
color you want yeah it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what color it is doesn't
color matter what type of mileage it's
got
doesn't matter if they set it on fire
and they reconstruct it that's not your
job
your job is to sell
the
appointment and i started thinking about
it
took me like three or four days to think
about what the [ __ ] is this guy talking
about
this guy's smarter than [ __ ] i can't i'm
a dumb [ __ ] i can't figure this out
and you know what i made a conscious
decision i was like i'm gonna stick to
the [ __ ] script
that's it
i went home and i studied that
[ __ ] those three weeks i was
suspended
every night lee before i get coked up
you know i would study the script for an
hour i wrote it down
and i was this was
this was
post-prison
this is when i had a kid and i was
really trying to put the pieces together
so i wanted to make a little bit more
money i wanted to make five grand
instead of 3 200 i was stuck at like 3
200 a month 2800 a month that's [ __ ]
after taxes
that was [ __ ] after taxes in those days
there were guys that were walking out of
a five [ __ ] grand the [ __ ] month
you know
so i listened to this guy
i really didn't listen to him i did
everything by the book lease i had
people were coming in with their wallets
i was in shock
he had six pointers on that sheet of
paper come on guys it's been 30 years i
don't remember
but they all went back to the
appointment
don't take your focus off the
appointment what's the mileage the
mileage is average i remember that one
the mileage is average what time can you
come in and look at the car uh i live in
whatever that's 30 minutes you know like
he just had all six of them and if you
kept going back to them your job was to
wear the [ __ ] customer out
so yeah so when one can come in um
i can't i have work today okay so if you
can't come in today what time can you
come into that we're here until nine
o'clock
uh
what am i gonna where are you where do
you work uh i work at the the the home
depot that's six miles away i'll tell
you what i'll drive the car over to you
i mean these [ __ ] were
relentlessly wow
so anyway you put it i did it i went
back on the phones
and one day at a meeting like
four weeks later he goes by the way i
got to tell you something
you know at the best month in here
ever
and people like oh it was sats there was
an indian guy that worked there then
that was very good and there was another
white dude that worked there it was very
good this time and he goes no joey diaz
that people wait what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
and he goes i'm talking about
percentages of people that came through
the door
i learned a lot about that
like i was if i would talk to 10 people
eight people come to the door well it
sounds similar to what you were talking
about about the founder to me last night
that i don't think you mentioned yet is
what be of know what you're selling
know what you're selling absolutely
because you know i don't want to spoil
it for them so i don't want to mention
that gotcha but it's really weird that
that let i tell you how good it got
that that guy and i started going to
lunch every wednesday
when he would come he would do the
meeting
we would go on the floor try to sell a
car and me and him and i became his name
was like jim that was his first name
he was from southern california and he'd
fly into denver every [ __ ] wednesday
and he comes to boulder toyota with a
[ __ ] tremendous suit on
tremendous hair always very neat
nails done shoes polished color
coordinated
and i got so good at getting
appointments from that man
that every wednesday for like three
months until i left the dealership every
wednesday
him and i went out to [ __ ] lunch were
you making appointments for yourself
no i was making an appointment for the
dealership i was getting people to come
into the dealership so in turn listen
when you're
when you're selling cars
savages stand outside
you even go to a car dealership because
people they're out there working on
their tan no they're savages
they're trying to get you you're parked
in the back of a lot
because you see a car you like and you
read the sticker and all of a sudden
somebody goes boop it's a car salesman
they're lurking back there that's where
the professionals work where people
gonna sneak in
if you uh
if you know chandler right on the end of
it on the van nuys right if you're
coming back uh
east
there's people there's always like a
group of them by the mercedes-benz one
smoking
right in the back there's like eight of
them
that must be a [ __ ] like
see but see if i owned the mercedes-benz
dealership i would not allow that yeah i
was not allowed to have salesmen smoking
anywhere on the property
because as soon as i'm if i'm a decent
person
i don't want people smoking my mercedes
right now it's really weird mercedes
people are very weird so that's really
rude that
that's how much like i was really
raised in that salesman type of i just
wasn't ready for it where's tony
black yeah
[Music]
[Music]
it's monday [ __ ] smokers
take the stick out of your ass it's life
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
lsd
let me get some shout outs here to my
people lorne rosenka always on point
i have not seen or heard from ali baz
the horse warrior so if anybody's seen
from him tell him i'm looking for that
sucker okay spooky nothing but love
brian callahan trying to get him on the
podcast in september
jam cgg
ray quigley ricky g
fremont street picks
and chris norcross i got you [ __ ]
don't forget thursday friday saturday
this week ontario [ __ ] improv
nobody's going to be there sadly because
of the mcgregor fight what am i going to
do i can't compete with that but if you
don't want to pay the yardstick a little
joke uncle joey will be there for you
ontario improv ontario mall
ontario california that's all i [ __ ]
know right well don't ask me what any
[ __ ] questions
what what the [ __ ] are you looking at
[ __ ]
thank uh again i wanted to thank rogan
for putting me on the other day that was
amazing i had a blast i did not know
that uh
the podcast was gonna turn into [ __ ]
stories that was not my intention that
was not pre-rehearsed that was not
pre-recorded that was not pre-discussed
rogan usually takes the higher road i
don't know if i took the lower road or
whatever
but like i said on that podcast we were
having a good time you know i have
feelings
i have feelings bro
i really do guys will people be me being
mean to you about your heart no i'm a
[ __ ] savage okay
but i got feelings just like anybody
else
and you know what i'm a big dude bro but
i get really [ __ ] sensitive
you never know and every once in a while
i read posts
for some reason i'll get caught on
reading something you ever go through
facebook and you're just looking to for
your [ __ ] dear dear dear friends to
see what the [ __ ] they're saying
but also you stumble on some stupidity
and you look into it you're like what
the [ __ ]
there's this lady who post on my [ __ ]
not on my page she just post i could see
once a month she books a comedy show
in l.a
and she just
destroys comics like myself and
like she just goes nuts like
you know her hands are like are you
tired
of seeing dirty comedy are you tired of
seeing comedy that bashes
political awareness
are you tired of comedy that bashes
the lgbt community are you looking for
thought-provoking comedy
are you looking for insightful and
intelligent comedy
come to our shows on wednesday at eight
and it's got seven [ __ ] stiffs
one worse than the other because no
one's gonna get through all that list
that sounds terrible listen guys you
will put a gun in your mouth do you hate
fun
so she every once in a while she'll put
a tape up of her shoes
and it's 25 people
they all have you know different this
you know they're all
special people
okay they're very [ __ ] special
she shows like the little after party in
front of the [ __ ]
this closet that she books
and it's
listen when i read that type of stuff i
get it
i understand that there's people that
want to go watch a comedian that's witty
and
i enjoy it i enjoy a lot of comedians
that are witty some guys are too witty
and that's what pisses me off
they can't sell it but there's a lot of
comics that i like that type of wit
there's one guy at the store that
[ __ ] kills me
you know i like uh ian
edwards edwards his his wit is
tremendous i love [ __ ] neil brennan
you know i am mine guys like that i wish
i could write like that but that's not
who i am
but like neil brennan doesn't bash
dirty comics near does he and
edward edwards you know there's a
handful of those comics so
i read those facebook ads and
it just it doesn't piss me off
it just makes me go wow
that [ __ ] [ __ ] exists that
somebody uses that type of [ __ ]
language to sell a show because maybe
they're frustrated or
i've read [ __ ] oh my god she once put
an ad in there about a year ago
that why go to comedy clubs and see
commercial comedy
when you can see real comedy here on
tuesday night it's like it's like
they're starting fights that don't exist
it's like why not just say come and see
witty comedy like why are you bashing
what i do now for no reason
[Music]
like that that doesn't seem like a fun
well
she's not bad
she's bashing it
in a backhanded way that's what [ __ ]
gets to me that instead of just coming
out and said then she said something
else then
uh when ari taped the [ __ ]
show at the cheetah
like after he taped the comedy central
thing okay she did one and she goes why
go watch a show that's going to be
cutting edge stories
so uh
uh
com they could sell commercial space
when you could tell your real story here
oh no no it's a [ __ ] nightmare and i
know it's frustration
i know it's not that she hates that
solid comedy
i know that maybe she's a comic and
she's frustrated so she lashed for years
i had a friend that would tell me to my
face
for you to do sets at the comedy store
you got to be a [ __ ] guido like you
and i would go i'm the only [ __ ]
guido down there
you know at that time it was wheels and
vinnie favorite oven if i read it went
to vegas wheels is in vegas
what are you talking about you know
there's just people who get angry
because they're not getting spots so
right my point was that day we were
laughing
we were laughing
joe's an intelligent guy and he was
[ __ ] laughing
tom segura we've we've been on planes
because thompson goober and his wife
don't don't they podcast
aren't they surrounded about [ __ ]
stories and [ __ ] farting on planes
and
[ __ ] your pants at the airport
i mean surrounded the
that's pretty much a powerful person i'm
par for the course so yeah
you know i mean if i get together and
they call brown talk if i get together
with tom
he'll talk to me about certain
situations
and he'll ask me if i if i saw a certain
something
and i'll [ __ ] laugh with him you know
tom is a great guy to be around
because he kind of laughs at my [ __ ]
humor
you know he gets it he doesn't mind that
i'm dirty it's really funny like gabriel
lacy's
gabrieles is a funny [ __ ] dude
that really perfects his act in being
clean and whatnot
if i'm with gabriel on a [ __ ] club
and i hope i'm not sounding like i'm
dropping them
if i'm a gamer at a club
and we're just talking we're [ __ ]
howling
and i could be i know i could be filthy
as [ __ ]
and before i go on stage he'll come up
with me and go dog
do that joke about pulling the tampon
out of something felipe
it's really weird the comics that don't
do it
like i admire a witty comic
yeah because it's not the way you do i
feel that they do a lot more work than i
do
but do you think maybe witty comics
might be
jealous of the way that you can
command a crowd or
no if i was a witty comic i wouldn't
give a [ __ ] what anybody was doing
i know i was i was leaving i was i know
you were leaving
and you were really thinking about what
i spoke about like that's how i think
about it to be honest with you
so that's why i like seinfeld i always
like slime tone
i went i paid to see jerry seinfeld and
90 [ __ ] three or two i'm gonna see
him i'm seeing him eventually
the tickets are bucking the corner now i
think i paid like 28
i got a good deal back then
so that's why that conversation arose on
the rogan podcast
not because i went up there planning on
telling the [ __ ] stories they took me by
surprise too
it took me by surprise when you let me
tell the second one
the [ __ ]
i haven't all the one uh
in uh kentucky kentucky and uh
whatever that time was yeah you know i
told tom i had we were in brayer one
night
and i told i told the story on stage
and this is way before storytelling was
around this one we were doing brain it
was like 100 people there
and i told that stupid story of me going
to a club and the girl
i can't blame myself again i don't want
to say it on this [ __ ] podcast so
disgusting
it's one of those disgusting stories we
were just on a [ __ ] roll in the rogan
podcast talking [ __ ]
so it went kind of [ __ ] awry you know
it's just it's
as a
podcast fan
it's pretty cool just a thousand like i
don't know any other podcast that's
gotten that to that number yet and
especially with him and you on the show
and instagram i mean
how many you must've been on that what
30 40 times
20 times i don't know
i don't know i try to really space him
out well you know
like i said i can call him and go on
there every two weeks and he'll make up
some show on why he's putting me on
there
number one i don't want to
affect our friendship
and number two
i don't want to do his podcast every
week right no i now i i want people to
go what the [ __ ] you want you live on
there so
i i do do one thing people this i do do
i do know that when i go on this podcast
i'm [ __ ] prepared
i'm like i go to bed early the night
before i do exercises when i before i go
up there
i want to be mentally prepared to deal
with him in that podcast that
i will not lie to you that i do well i
think even just
going back to the catalog
with
the ones that you've been on the early
early early ones like people are
favorites
like i i don't know that i don't
remember the numbers but some of the
early ones when you guys were on the
couch
are uh
like someone's gonna eventually do a
podcast history course
like i think one of the podcasts that i
remember going on there really [ __ ]
laughing
was the prison one
that was the first time i remember
like there was two points in my
podcasteria
that i really remember laughing from my
heart
like that i was almost gonna die
when you were talking about them
screaming
when i was talking about no not the
christian podcast okay one time
one of the first times i really
discovered laughter on podcasting
was felicia and i were doing a podcast
now
felicia loved the spit thing
what do you call the black little circle
you put in front of the microphone oh
yeah pop filter pop filter sort
and we was we would sit a certain way
that i really i could see felicia
but not really
and
we were talking about something and i
told the story about when i mugged the
hooker
and lit her wig on fire like that was
like i for some reason again
the best stories come out not when you
plan them guys
it's when you don't plan them
and you lay something and the timing is
right and nobody pauses you are you
really
are you surprised that people have that
reaction to
mugging a hooker and letting her wig on
fire the reaction
was
[ __ ]
[Music]
mind-boggling
but the podcast was as small as such a
small
level at that time
that nobody really heard it we were
getting like maybe 2 000 downloads a
week
but the problem with that story is that
was the beginning of my podcast career
because i'm telling the story
and i'm not looking at felicia michaels
i'm looking straight ahead while i'm
telling the story
and all of a sudden when we told the
story about dragging the chicken to the
cemetery
and [ __ ] making her strip
i look over felicia the corner of my eye
and her jaw is completely [ __ ]
dropped and if you listen to the podcast
and she was editing them at that time
but if she didn't net it you could tell
i didn't finish the story
because looking at her and i knew we
were onto something
i knew that day when i saw her draw drop
and then the rogan podcast
when i told the story about going to
prison
and this you know guys
as [ __ ] up as it sounds
these couple days
were miserable
but then again they were fun
i had gotten sentenced august 15th
okay
on august 18th i got shipped to summit
county
i stayed in summit county for maybe a
week
so maybe like on the 25th
i went to the department of corrections
and that's when you go to canyon city
you go to processing
i sat in there for four days and then
five more days of processing
and then they said they were going to
send me to missouri here there
blah blah blah blah well guess what
[ __ ]
i don't want to go to rifle i want to go
to rifle
prison because
see if they still got a a prison in
rifle colorado
see if they still got a prison rifle
colorado
this was crazy rifle colorado was five
hours from boulder
at the time it probably still is maybe
four and a half if you're [ __ ] lucky
yeah but they still haven't
rival correction center let me see pop
it up on the screen and this is crazy
that 30 years later they still got this
[ __ ] place so everybody
told me i was eligible for two places at
that time
i was eligible for rifle
or i was eligible for uh
golden which was uh camp george west
you want to click onto it which one do
you want it's gonna be a web page or
something
this was crazy guys this was the place
where you wanted to be in the system
because they had a swimming pool
you got a job at the swimming pool
or you got the job in the movie theater
or you got a job at the sl at the ski
slope
this was the [ __ ] prison i wanted to
be at
and i got a [ __ ] tap on the [ __ ]
shoulder one morning wake the [ __ ] up
[ __ ]
we're taking you to your destination
and i look at the guy and i go if i go
on a rifle he goes no you're going to
golden
to camp george west and i freakily
yeah there's nothing there's nothing on
there i freaked not because i'm scared i
don't think they tell you about the
movie theater in the in them no they
won't tell you about that maybe it's
changed now but i freaked because
the whole time they were telling me i
was going to camp george west
they were going to tell me i was going a
rifle
i had all the qualifications in the
world to go to [ __ ] rifle
they were like ah we don't know about
camp george west camp george west is
very selective
they're not going to probably take you
because you had a violent crime i would
tell them it's not a violent crime they
would say it depends how they look at it
and ba boom
ended up in camp george west i got there
i met with a counselor right away they
tell you go
they'll tell you go see the kitchen but
the inmates will go you don't want a job
in the kitchen
for me lee
i had gone through
20 days of what i thought was gonna be
hell
what i thought i thought i was gonna get
raped
i thought i was gonna get beat up i
thought somebody's gonna want to come up
to me and [ __ ] me or something
nothing happened
i read a book
i got off the marijuana habit i realized
i could live without marijuana
i realized the crime i had done and
there was nothing i could do
there was no escape i wasn't thinking of
escaping
there was the appeal process and there
was the what the judge had told me
that in 120 days to file a motion for
reconsideration sentencing
and that's all i could do
and here i was
in the place i didn't want to be at i
didn't want to be at camp george west i
didn't even know why that's how dumb i
was at that that's how [ __ ] dumb i
thought you wanted to be there no
and guess what camp george west was 45
minutes from boulder
like i could have people visit me there
but i want to do my time in rifle
because everybody said i'm right for you
could [ __ ] do this and do that
and go to the movie theater and
so when i went to camp george west
once i got there
i was like holy [ __ ] i hit the jackpot
you just didn't know it
no i didn't know it i didn't know i was
[ __ ] 40 minutes from the house and
i didn't know like getting a job like
they said to me don't get a job in the
kitchen
don't you don't want to work in the game
where do you want to work you want to
work outside you want to work and you
know
[ __ ] there's a janitor maybe in the
laundry room
you want to work maybe get permission to
go outside
those people who you see on the side of
the roads
picking up [ __ ] that's a good that's
what you want to do yeah i wanted to be
outside in the sun
because people could drop off packages
for it
so i could tell you where i'm gonna be
and you could tell me where a package is
and then on the way back they really
don't search it you throw it in the back
of the truck one of the bags and they
don't search it they trust you
it was crazy how those guys were making
money in prison
and i thought i was going to do the same
thing
so no no no no no
the guy says to me blue mr blue i said
because before when i got there you have
to wait online to talk to your counselor
so the inmates are coming up to me
asking me questions and then they would
tell me listen
if they ask you if you have hepatitis
telling me
like if you had something bronchitis or
something
tell them that you've had it so you
don't have to work in the kitchen
i go they're gonna look at my medical
records
it's the dumbest thing in the world
why was it good to have that
i don't know because then you couldn't
get a job in the kitchen if you at one
time had
a pneumonia i forget what the disease
was
that you had to have to not work in the
kitchen i was just about to say how
brilliant all these people are but then
they have weird stuff like that that
just doesn't make sense
so i would want to be in the kitchen i
went to the counselor and he goes uh
what are you going to do while you're
here what do you want to do and like i
don't know what type of program you got
and he told me
and he told me that you know i was good
aptitude wise i should really consider
being a judge like a
an attorney in the jail
and i told him that wasn't gonna happen
and
that was it he goes uh go see
the dude in the kitchen he's looking for
people
and he goes have you ever had hepatitis
or whatever and i go no he goes go see
the dude
i didn't have to go in that kitchen
i did not have to get people when i
don't go in the kitchen
so i was like you know what man i'm just
happy to be here
i'm going to go to the kitchen i went to
the [ __ ] kitchen
mr something with a big [ __ ]
black dude
big [ __ ] black dude
old like uh army guy navy guy 20 years
service man ran a kitchen in there you
know
high level kitchen
dude ah i wish i could remember his name
guys was he a car or was he and he was
uh he was the head chef he was in charge
of the kitchen
he went home every day
okay he was an outsider that came in
big black dude with glasses he looked
like bb king only six foot [ __ ] six
big dude you know
he had a couple black dudes working in
the kitchen a couple of white dudes
and he goes you're getting a job in the
[ __ ] kitchen i go okay and he goes
can you bake
bake i have a big nut in my [ __ ] life
bake
so he goes you're gonna be a baker
so i would have to get up at five and go
down there
and the first day i had to make like
muffins or something like that i forget
me
and that was cool
and i got to eat extra muffins and i got
to eat extra eggs which were disgusting
you know there was nothing you didn't
eat like eggs with a yolk that was the
good eggs no these were powdered nasty
[ __ ]
so the second day i got there they had
to make cinnamon
things what do you call them cinnamon
rolls cinnamon rolls that was my
favorite and yeah you had like they had
like a gun or something you got to make
them a certain size i didn't want them
that size
i wanted them bigger so i put them all
in the oven dog
the oven caught fire they get bigger
when they put them in something [ __ ]
up with me man oh my god you know the
first batch went bad and the second
batch went on fire
then the third batch he came out young i
mean what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
nobody's ever been this stupid
look at the size of these muffins they
look like little flying saucers you know
those things you throw in the olympics
they were that big
they were gigantic and it was like
a discus that's what they look like they
didn't even taste like cinnamon they
tasted like [ __ ] cardboard it was
horrible
i didn't know what i was [ __ ] doing i
don't know how to bake what the [ __ ] do
i know about bacon
you look like you could learn how to
bake yeah nah nah that's not my fourth
day
do you have to have a job and yeah [ __ ]
yeah because that's what gets you a good
time
that should get you good behavior and
stuff like that
so on the way out he goes i got another
job for you you got your driver's
license i go yup
he goes man it's tough getting somebody
with a driver's license in there why
because i know if you're going to
[ __ ] jail you obviously lost your
license like they chased you oh my god
something there's always something with
those guys
there was one guy in there that wasn't
gonna he was young too he wasn't gonna
just get his license so he was [ __ ]
92.
they took the license from him for like
30 years something crazy something crazy
because he led cops
on a high-speed chase you lose your oh
yeah you get all those points that
did something do not
quote me on this for sure but he did
something that
like high speed and something else
he drew because they you pick up
different charges
for different things like he ran 89 stop
signs
so each stop sign is like three points
like they [ __ ] them somewhere
but yeah he was like so nobody has a
license
so my job basically was
i got there early
i ate breakfast
i what the [ __ ] i wanted to
i could tell the the chef the head chef
was a black dude
and his name was spencer anton
and he was from new orleans about 30
minutes out of new orleans and he was
tougher than debt
and he was in there from voluntary
manslaughter
and his sous chef with the black dude
named etchy
i don't know where the [ __ ] edgy was
from
and there was another guy that worked in
the kitchen he was on the fryer his name
was big t he was from buffalo
big t was [ __ ] huge dark
and all you could see and then one of
the [ __ ] dudes that worked in the
kitchen
was the [ __ ]
torey pile from denver was like a race
thing that did they didn't want to go in
there
no it was there was only out of 10 guys
that worked in the kitchen three of them
were white
because mr yarborough that was his name
mr yarber was black
so he he liked the black invex
so
in the mornings i had to get there
and carry out four boxes of sandwiches
to trucks
to a truck a little toyota truck
and i'd have to start the truck up
drive 50 yards to the guards gate they
would open up the guard's gate
and then i would drive 100 yards down
the road
where four different vehicles would back
up
and one guy would come on every truck i
wasn't allowed to get out of the car
one guy would come out every truck and
take out a [ __ ]
thing and go in that truck
before they left i made a u-turn and
went back to the gate
they looked in the truck they would be
watching me
did you regard with you in the car huh
did he have a guard with you no no no no
by myself wow so they let me drive on
150 yards one way
and 150 yards to the other
so once i did that and i pulled back in
they go joey just pull it over there i
pull it over there
that was it
all right so
it would probably be seven a.m then
i think the invic said eight that eat at
eight
i would already be fed by seven o'clock
my breakfast
what i wanted
that's why you like that job now the
first week i didn't get what i wanted
because i didn't know the ins and outs
so boom from there i went back to my
room and took a
nap right i would go back to my room and
take a nap and then about 11 30
i would go back to the kitchen and
that's when the orders and the
deliveries are coming
for like what the people out in the
field no for the people in the kitchen
what they got like canned meat canned
potatoes
chocolate pudding
all that [ __ ] is canned
so what i would have to do is is leave
pull the orders out that i would leave
for the kitchen
and then take the other orders
i didn't even take them i had a dude who
loaded them and [ __ ] took my little
cart
to the back house there was a back house
about
150 yards from the kitchen
in the back of the prison right close to
the fence
and there was a camera in the back of
the [ __ ] fence not the front of the
fence it was crazy
you could do drugs over there and stuff
so once i started i would go back there
open up the gate
after about a week they just gave me the
keys
so in the daytime when i wasn't doing
deck i could walk back there
and i would just go back there and sit
and be by myself
and then somebody told me that they
don't check the guard shed they don't
check that
when the dogs come they never take their
dogs out that far
so your heads up there
well i consider hiding heroin back there
bought balloons heroin
[Music]
these mexican divots i was like sure
and these black dudes came up to me like
can you hide rigs back there and
steroids
how did you suddenly own this thing i
had this pla i i was stashing
this [ __ ] and the weirdest places man
and i couldn't miss a day's work
because if i miss a day's work and
somebody else had to go back there and
pull something they would find one of
the steroids
i would hide the food i would hide the
the food the heroin and the syringes
either under pallets
but i hid them in food
and i'd pull the food out and i'd put
them like in the middle so you got to
pull off 10 boxes to find that [ __ ]
you know
yeah so
god
and how much money would you make of all
that and other stuff ten dollars a week
and a ton of privileges
like the dudes that brought the heroine
in the mexican dudes
if they brought burritos in i was the
first one to get a bag on the heart you
know i'm saying bam right off the bat
all the respect
they knew i liked that green chili
burritos
i remember the one guy's name was louis
anaya
and he was about 20 something and his
uncle was in there also his real blood
uncle was in there
and he was cooler than [ __ ]
and louis and i was from the east side
of denver and his uncle was from the
east side of denver lewis and i as his
uncle i don't remember what his name was
he was a little older but he was really
his blood uncle
and they weren't too fond of each other
but that dude used to bring me [ __ ]
burritos out of respect because i'd hook
him up with the kitchen
when you work in the kitchen you can
hook people up
would you get in trouble for it no
nobody knew
so you would come to me and go joey man
you know i'm a fat [ __ ] dog joey
this [ __ ] don't give me enough
meat give me five bucks
i would take that five bucks and give it
to the guy that pours the meat
and tell him when lee comes by make sure
he gets
double the [ __ ] meat
wow so you come to me the second week
and go doug
can i give you three dollars a [ __ ]
week
instead of five i'd go [ __ ] you give me
12 a month i wouldn't even touch it
so that black dude i was giving money to
he's got three kids
he loved me
and he loved you what is he gonna do
with twelve dollars a week
twelve dollars a weekly is forty eight
dollars a month
when you're in jail
and you wanna buy cigarettes or you
wanna go to the chinese restaurant
and not
you know instead of can you imagine
if you're fighting for your life if i
said to you lee you don't have to send
me no money oh and you're like you know
what yeah but he's not helping his kids
out i'm just saying
lee
if i'm not taking food out of my wife's
mouth i'm helping my kids in one way or
the other that's also true and i'm not
doing a crime i'm just giving a little
chubby jew who likes more meat
extra [ __ ] food every week
you know the van plus a hookup so now
you know that i take care of you so now
one day if i'm in the library and say
somebody says do you hey [ __ ]
he'll go hey man no no no no don't mess
with elise solid
you're following me it's business
that black dude that i give the three
dollars to he loves me how do you get
money in prison
you put in your pocket you hide it
unless they stop you which they're never
gonna stop you
but you you can have money because you
have to go to the store
right yeah so you can't just have three
thousand dollars in your pocket but it's
in your account right like that's what i
was confused about
you have money in your account right
that you can get or you can have money
from
in there from selling let's say you want
to sell cookies
you can bake cookies and sell cookies at
night for a dollar
or trade them with people for cigarettes
or
if they bring burritos on sundays or
[ __ ] like that it's really amazing you
really learn this complete different
way of doing commerce
everything is on the arm
and you know the rules you can't shake
me down because you know i don't get my
potato chips till thursday
so if i come to you and i go lee you got
any chips yeah they're gonna cost you
two bags joey good
you know on thursday you're getting two
bags of chips
because you gave me one on tuesday
so now you become a star
you go you know what i'm a [ __ ] jew
well why am i [ __ ] with these black
[ __ ] these white [ __ ]
i'm gonna get my own store so instead of
buying two bags you buy the excess every
week
they know what you're doing from the
commissary yeah
you buy you even go to black dudes and
go dog what do you want chocolate chip
cookies yeah man how much you're gonna
charge me i charge you 25 25 cents on
the back man you're stubborn at least
how you i got you who got you like lisa
does
so you so
that's how the stunt talking that guy
survives he wants to he gets his cookies
you know why because at night he likes
watching a white show and he likes
dipping his [ __ ] cookies and milk
that's the only satisfaction that makes
him feel like he's at home when he's in
the prison cell do you understand you
sell an emotion
so they get it you got to make a living
they got to make a living you can also
say hey dog
you work in the laundry room right yeah
hook me up with an extra blanket in the
wintertime
bam
you could also say hey man you work in
the kitchen right yeah
let me get some extra [ __ ] eggs in
the morning whatever lee that's the
barter system in there
and you look at it and for drugs and
[ __ ] it's weird but i was never involved
in the drug end of it but is it true
like in the movies and tv where they're
like don't do a favor for anybody
because then then
you'll owe them something
but
but you know who you're dealing with
when you get in there
you feel them out you smell the people
that will come up to you
and they're trying to the for the second
day i was there
i still remember what this guy looks
like
and i still remember what his two
partners look like
they came up to me as new yorkers
what's up dog
upper west side what stop brooklyn
what's up the bronx
three white dudes
one they were all filthy [ __ ] junkies
so they came up to me what's up oh yeah
you're with us we're going to hook you
up we're going to teach you what it's
all about in here
they carried my [ __ ] to my room
they offered me a [ __ ] soul i told
them i already knew what time it was
the [ __ ] thing
i sat with them i could watch every
[ __ ] guard watching me
next you know i went back to my room i
had guards checking me out every 15
minutes you know why because these three
guys were heroin magnus
so finally it took like two days for the
[ __ ] clouds to part
and the true colors that hey man what's
up dog listen man
i don't know if you know what the game
is in here
we could get you the stuff or we could
get you the cotton ball afterwards like
to shoot the [ __ ] that doesn't go into
the needle
don't give you the cotton ball like
you're doing me a big [ __ ] favor
and they'll start with that [ __ ]
story
how about if you let my sister put money
on your book
listen man
there's a federal case i got and they
got my [ __ ] money tied up
i can't do nothing on my banks i got my
[ __ ]
girlfriend giving me 25 bucks a week
come on man no i can't do it that's the
first nail watch this is my finances
so the first thing they come to you is
try to money you somewhere
there's always a story i'm not going to
do this till now you've been long you've
been out there long enough you know
who's looking to take advantage
so once i got then i met somebody else i
forget who it was and they told me to
stay clear of those people they were
just and within two days i was getting
pissed tested
because they just saw you with them and
they're like yeah within two days so i
knew right there i avoided all the drug
people
all the people that were known drug
people i avoided them
and you know what i never got a drug
test again this is the rest of the seven
months i was in there
you never looked for coke
not even once
i knew that i was in there for that and
that was the last thing i was going to
do wow i did not smoke pot either
i did a couple hits of
blotter acid
that was it because they couldn't test
for that
they couldn't test for it how is acid in
prison that sounds i think what i've
talked about once but it sounds terrible
well
first off here's the deal they watch you
every night
and they watch your
patterns in those days the cameras
weren't how they were today
but the guards were very active
he was don't even know his minimum
security
you had to walk through every half hour
and you had two or three different
people who did the walkthroughs
when these people walk through
they look in your room and they're like
lee syed is an insomniac
he's got a tv in there he has earplugs
because after 10 you have to put
earplugs like the little white one with
one ear
yeah the earbuds like the earbuds but
there will only be one
so after 10 you were
so let's pretend you did that every
night
one o'clock you watch tv and some nights
the guard would come in and hit you in
the foot and go what are you watching
and you're like this stupid movie with
john candy and it's [ __ ] hilarious
you know he would talk to you and look
at your words
make sure you weren't sweat uh
your mouth wasn't moving like you were
doing meth
he smelled your breath not he didn't
smell like go breathe in my nose but
when you walk in the room you can see
alcohol right after two months of this
he knows lisa asks an insomniac
okay so when he walks around at one in
the morning and he sees the tv on in
leigh's room
he knows lee's not doing a mess
so you so you don't do the first night
you're in jail you do it once you let
them know that you stay up late anyway
no so you set them up like with my case
i was always an insomniac once they took
away weed my sweet sleep problems really
started not to sleep out here that was
when my sleep patterns went off
so when i got to this camp
you know i would lay there for as long
as i could
it wasn't cable tv
you had three channels then four
channels
it wasn't cable in prison there was four
channels and you gotta have a hangar in
your tv to get all four of them
so at night i would walk
so i would get out and go in front of my
bunker
in front of my building there was a
there was two
uh benches and you could sit on the
benches
and just sit there
so i would go out there every night
around 10 30
and just sit on the bench
and look around till midnight and one
o'clock
they would come by and ask me what are
you doing out there nothing
and then when people found out i'd do
that a couple people come out of their
[ __ ] barracks
and one of the guys that came out was a
guy from the library
and he was an intellectual type of guy
and he would just come out and [ __ ]
talk to me about whatever he rolled his
own cigarettes
i'll never forget that guy either that
his glasses
the little blue jacket he used to wear
he was the original one one of those
people i just mentioned
with the tight pants
the hipsters he was the original hipster
he had tight pants already he wore the
janitor jacket he had a hat he had a
beard
so he would come over and stand while i
was sitting
and we would talk and there was a black
guy that started coming out and talking
to us and he was like born again
so we would sit out there till 12 12 30.
and they don't mind no as long as you
get to work in the morning then we give
a [ __ ] rest out there all night
and on the weekends me and that dude
would stand there till three talking
[ __ ]
about buffalo history
current affairs i would ask him stupid
questions about the law he was very
knowledgeable
so the night we did acid
we popped the acid about seven
so it was okay acid it's around 8 30. by
11 we were [ __ ] giggling our asses
off so we split up
and we decided to do what we did every
night
go back out there on 12.
god just so we went back out so we would
have stayed out there from there with
another sun was uh
something was off course
when something's off course
two days later they had dogs in your
building
or they piss you or both
nothing could be out of order any other
nights
that's how they pick pack the junkies
because they'll go by a junkies room
he's sleeping
or he's knotted out they catch those
guys they're the easiest ones to catch
and they'll go in their rooms that night
and not say dick to them
but the next morning right now they're
waking up to [ __ ] ten dogs
and a p test in two hours or you go
right back to prison
if you come back positive you go back to
the big prison too
they're taking people back every other
day
people really think they can get high
and then get away with it they watch
everything but not
really
i have a fun time doing all this stuff
it definitely
it definitely helps me sleep
i can't imagine
breaking the law about if like god
forbid i ever went into
prison and now it's comply i can't even
imagine now i can't even imagine you
know i was telling people that boulder
colorado in 1990
one was voted in the number one jail in
the country to go
number two was craig colorado i'm not
even kidding hi on yelp
no this is way before yelp this was just
a bunch of inmates i had just started
comedy
and i'll never forget reading that i
wrote a joke about trident gum 4 out of
5 dentists surveyed recommended
and i wrote a joke did you hear that
boulder was voted number one jail in the
country
four out of five convicts surveyed
recommended boulder county jail the
other kind of jail
that was the [ __ ] truth
boulder jail was the number one jail in
the country where people wanted to be
locked up but
because they gave you juice they gave
you milk they had cable tv they had
carpeting
they had couches and carpeting in the
[ __ ] jail
who did the survey
they asked a bunch of convicts
from across the country what was the
number one yeah
and like anchorage they had the top five
[ __ ] jails the top five county jails
that's so funny and boulder county was
number one people would go to bold and
committed misdemeanor
wouldn't be able to pay to try it out
they would go to jail for the winter
instead of paying rent they would go to
boulder county jail for the winter they
gave you cigarettes
three squares you got to do exercise you
go to church
are there people who do that like that
jailhop
they do that brother oh no they [ __ ]
do that
idiots now listen man that that's the
mentality in there the the the one that
the the thing that kills you tonight
the thing that kills you the most when
you get locked up is
when you hear people talking about the
places where they've been
and we've discussed this before huh
yeah i've been to [ __ ] this place
i partied with lisa hat's uncle no [ __ ]
yeah man we partied out for four in the
morning how the [ __ ] do you party in
prison
hit me god damn it
i think i lost my glasses like that tell
me everybody
i think i've lost my mediocre
i said i think i lost my mediocre glass
i got up early and went to right at the
coffee shop this morning oh that's uh i
think i lost my mediocre glasses i
really like these [ __ ] glasses but
that's what happens when you're an old
[ __ ]
i looked in the car i looked in the
house
i looked everywhere and i can't find
what's this here just don't say that all
right beautiful listen listen to me
i go to the airports
sometimes i go the owner i went to the
comedy store and uh my wife took the car
because she had to go home
and i took a lift and i got to tell you
something
i did it online
some kid helped me at the store because
lee wasn't around
the guy showed up in front of the store
within [ __ ] four minutes
we got in the car
hit laurel king and
we were home by
18 minutes later 16 minutes later
we spoke about sports the car was clean
he offered me a water
he had a purple light in front that said
lift i knew he was him immediately it
was just a [ __ ] tremendous experience
now lyft knows that their drivers are
going to keep them moving
so they do everything they can to make
sure that drivers are happy on every
trip
it's a simple formula happy drivers
means happy passengers and they made me
happy that night maybe that's why nine
out of 10 lift rides get a perfect five
star rating i gave the guy five
plus 22 more you can earn thousands of
dollars you could hurt
you could earn hundreds of dollars a
week plus tips you want to earn more
money drive more it's never been easier
to give yourself a raise nice and easy
you're not doing nothing you're sitting
around get in your car and do it three
or four runs you finish up your little
other job boom you do two more runs
you're earning that's the most thing
that's the most important thing you
heard it lyft was the first
rideshare platform with tipping built
right into the app
because getting tipped shouldn't depend
on your passenger having a crumpled
build in their pocket you dig you keep
100 of the tips and they add up fast
drivers have been paid over 200 million
dollars since the feature was first
introduced and express pay lets you get
paid almost instantly instead of waiting
for weeks lyft has even taken the
guesswork out of pickups the new amp
device uses color coding to help
passengers find their drivers i'm
telling you it's a beautiful thing so do
yourself a favor go join the ride
sharing company that believes in
treating its people better go to
lyft.com
joey today right now
go to go and get a 500
new driver bonus that's lynt.com
joey again
that's lyft.com
joey limited time only terms apply
you're just sitting there take a chance
columbus did number two i've been
telling you this for weeks people
on it
on it
on it
i've been hitting jiu jitsu when i'm at
home sometimes four times a week you
think that's because i'm better than you
no i'm a fat [ __ ] i still suck in jiu
jitsu but every time i go my wind is
better my recovery is better why
shroom tax board that's why the enforced
protein helps your recovery also at six
every scoop is 16 grams of protein oh my
god i can't tell you all the good stuff
they have new mood shroom tech immune
not to mention alpha brain you don't
like it
they give you 100 money back guarantee
and then i want the product back when
somebody does something like that i know
you're not [ __ ] around any way you
put it i love you guys don't forget
thursday friday saturday the ontario
improv if you don't want to pay 100 for
[ __ ] mayweather mcgregor come on down
[ __ ] lee syad i want to thank you for
being the co-host of the year [ __ ]
stay black i'll see you [ __ ] on
wednesday i got a surprise guest
tomorrow night you'll get another
wednesday stay black
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you